What number could
replace this weird circle
with an x symbol
looking thing below?
And over here, they
have this equation.
They say 8 plus 4 is equal
to 4 plus weird circle
with the x thing.
And what they're really
wanting us to appreciate
is that, look, 8 plus 4 is the
exact same thing as 4 plus 8.
That's the commutative
law of addition,
which is just a very fancy way
of saying that, well, 8 plus 4
is the same thing as 4 plus 8.
It doesn't matter which number
comes before the addition sign
and which one comes after.
So 8 plus 4 is the
same thing as 4 plus 8.
This little thing could be
replaced by the number 8.
Let's do another one.
What number could replace
this little-- looks
almost like a cross--
below, or it looks almost
like a dagger or something.
10 plus 4 in parentheses
plus 3, and then they
have something plus 4 plus 3.
So it looks like
they're wanting us
to realize that
it doesn't matter
if we do the 10 plus
4 first or whether we
do the 4 plus 3 first.
So if we just took this
statement right over here
and changed the
parentheses so that we
add the 4 plus 3 first--
so they're doing here--
this number right over
here could be the 10.
And this right over here is
just the associative law,
or the associative law
of addition, or the fact
that addition is associative.
It doesn't matter if you
add the 10 plus 4 first
and then you add the 3, or
you add the 4 plus 3 first
and then you add the 10.
So this could easily be the 10.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do another one.
What could replace this
little-- almost looks
like what you'd see in
a Do Not Smoking sign
if there was a cigarette
behind it, so this little
slash between the inside
of a circle below.
So 9 times 6.
Well, multiplication
is also commutative.
9 times 6 is the exact
same thing as 6 times 9,
so this thing could be a 9.
It could be replaced with a 9.
I guess I'm all
out of questions.